see this in the two versions of Mulan
when Mulan was first done the
protagonist is a smaller girl who needs
to be smarter and work harder she needs
to do all of these things to be able to
compensate for her size and because she
works really really hard she can use her
lack of size to her advantage and she
overcomes challenges and hooray she's
brilliant contrast that with the most
recent version of Milan this protagonist
doesn't have to do anything she's
naturally better than all of the men she
doesn't have to overcome any challenges
she's got this like magical feminine Chi
or whatever that allows her to be more
talented than all of the men and all of
the men are blundering and patronizing
and blah blah the first one is probably
directed by a man and the second one was
probably directed by a woman you think I
don't know Mulan director oh my God it's
a woman New Zealand film director was
the first one a man let me let me see uh
yes the 1998 version
thus it has been proved
wow